Buenos días soy María clara recordemos
que aquí la ceremonia en lo que
corresponde realmente a este funeral va
a comenzar a las 3 de la tarde cuando el
féretro de la reina llegue desde Londres
y recorra este longo que ustedes Ven a
mi derecha es el largo paseo de cerca 5
kilómetros que llega hasta la reja de el
Palacio de Windsor donde finalmente va a
descansar la Reina Isabel pero pese a
ello ya hay mucha gente se espera que
lleguen cerca de mil personas a estos
jardines y el ambiente es muy tranquilo
muy familiar estuvimos ya Ayer cuando
las personas venían en una suerte de
peregrinaje a visitar el castillo y a
dejar una ofrenda floral para la reina
Ahora las flores están prohibidas sin
embargo la gente sigue mostrando un gran
respeto por la reina por la familia real
pero también entre ellos y es lo que me
llama la atención el respeto ir
tranquilos sin correr ordenados por lo
que todo se Está realizando de manera
muy Tranquila recordemos que este
castillo de Windsor que desde hoy 19 se
transformó en la residencia permanente
de la Reina Isabel es el uno de sus
castillos favoritos aparte del Moral en
Escocia por lo tanto ella quiso
descansar aquí ya en los años 60 Ella
hizo construir esa capilla anexa a la
capilla de San Jorge donde van a
descansar sus restos con los de sus
padres su hermana Margarita y su difunto
marido el príncipe Felipe de edimburgo
hay gente que viene de todos lados del
Reino Unido sobre todo la gente que
viene más del Norte ayer yo estuve
conversando por ejemplo con una señora
que pasó la noche aquí Ella vino sola
pero se encontró con otras mujeres como
ella que sienten hoy decía ella un
verdadero orgullo de ser británico por
este personaje que es la Reina Isabel
por lo que significa esta democracia
parlamentaria no tan particular del
Reino Unido Y eso es lo que se siente
Aquí la gente viene a dar gracias a esta
figura tan importante para esta para
este país para esta nación